why don't the women want to cook and
clean for the men anymore because
they're tired bro they have to go to
work every day
that's not hard
they're tired
yeah they gotta go to work every day
just like you're ready what are they
tired of
of
working it's not hard i mean i shouldn't
even be like i don't i don't even
understand the question
like
they're tired aren't you tired when you
get home from work
they're working every day so they're
tired that's why i don't want to cook or
clean
my man's just repeating the answer so he
could try to figure out if he can have a
rebuttal why aren't the women uh cooking
and eating making food no more because
they're tired they're going home and
they're tired from work so you're
telling me it's because they're tired
from work that they're not cooking in
yeah they're tired
so what you're trying to tell me is that
because they got a job yeah
just what i said so what you're trying
to tell me
is that because
they're tired as a result of having a
job yeah they're tired
so what happens i'm gonna do attention
you think i wanna work eight hours and
then come home and
and then cook and clean i mean i do it
because i have to i have five children
but yeah i mean do you have a woman
right now
only what's that do you have a woman
right now
i've been married since uh i've been
married for over 20 years okay what what
is did your wife work
yeah absolutely you think it's easy
peasy like that like just saying that is
it's you
not having a woman and not knowing all
the [ __ ] cost
like you live at your own house
that's my question
because the minute you step out of your
mama house and you kind of
you like cheese on your [ __ ]
do you like cheese on your food
do you like that do you know how much
cheese cuts nowadays
you like milk and you see you know how
much that [ __ ] [ __ ] cost
[ __ ] the lights cheese [ __ ]
cheese do you like going places
going outside cost a lot yeah breathing
oxygen drinking water gas peep game peep
game peep game
when i used to have a nine to five
i would go to cuba in an all in queue
and all inclusive it would cost me about
900 dollars it would cost me less
than my week here
a week in cuba
cost me less than a week
but that's because communism is superior
yes but also
it's expensive outside
i don't know i don't if you don't get
that simple thing i don't know what you
get it they lazy [ __ ] you lazy too the
worst thing is that he just answered his
question right there you cut it but he
answered it he's like
yeah but i'm tired to go to work that's
why
after i go to work i'm tired too that's
why i don't want to cook and clean
then i guess we have a problem
then then you have to have a job
that makes sure that your women don't
work
in order for her to cook and clean the
reason why women used to cooking clean
they didn't have no
jobs that was their job
that's it
they didn't go to work their work was at
home
so i bring the money you bring the food
and that's fine there's some people that
are still like that
now if you want your woman to cook and
clean for you make sure that she cooks
it clean for you if that's what she
wants to do first and foremost get you a
girl that knows how to cook and clean
then after that get you someone that has
the time to cook
and clean well step three just let her
cook and clean and pay the bills
that's it
so what you're saying is if they don't
have a job they have the energy
what i'm saying is with the prices of
everything and stuff
nowadays
rent electric electricity bill gas bill
uh gas that you have to put in your car
groceries with the with the
with the amount of money it costs now
i don't know what kind of job you're
gonna let's say you live in new york
your rent is gonna be between
200
your rent is going to be
2025 2500 a month to
infinity and beyond buzz lightning let's
be let's be honest depending on
depending on what's every price all
right [ __ ] city but and i said i said
2500 yeah i'm not even sure there ain't
nothing left at 2500 for four there's a
bunch of new yorkers being like where
[ __ ] a closet yeah where clock
exactly even the car is gonna be it's
gonna be so let's say you're a new
yorker and you have a two bedroom
apartment
that's what's gonna be like what 35 40
hundred dollars
fine you got that and you're just one
person paying that i don't know what
kind of a job you're gonna have because
after that you have to you have to add
insurance you have to have electricity
and all of that so you have to be top
dollar living in an apartment having a
girl that cooks and clean
where you could be two people
in a team both of you are working both
of y'all separating all the today's
video is brought to you by t.h henley a
lot of people have been dropping
comments and saying that you know my
skin is wonderful and pristine well
thank you very much for the comments i
can help you to achieve that as well
because whenever you meet people that's
what they see
they're not going to remember what you
said but they sure are going to remember
how you looked and if your skin was
crumbsty
and if you don't know
where to start or how to apply those
wonderful products well simple i would
suggest you to get the stage one the
level one box because they have
different boxes and they have different
products in there and there's
instruction to each products in the box
you have a a daily face wash which gets
rid of all the dirt and grime on your
face then got it two times per week
exfoliating scrub to get rid of all the
dead skin cells and an am moisturizer
with spf 20 because we all need to make
sure that our skin is protected from the
sun so click on the link below and we're
happy to be partners with the lee for
this video because i like their products
and they're supporting us and by getting
those products for you you have one a
clear skin and you're able to support us
too so get you click on the link below
you're gonna have your 30 off your box
and
a free gift yeah they're gonna throw in
the gift ain't that great
[Music]
what are you talking about roles
everybody does what they have to do
okay what's your what do you do what
does she do
for a living no in the house for the
marriage what do you guys do what are
your roles
well i i don't i don't understand the
question i
she does she does what needs to be done
that day if she has time to do it if she
doesn't i do it
i do what needs to be done that day and
if i don't have time to do it she does
it roles i don't know how do you not how
do you not know what roles are in a
marriage you're married for 20 years you
see the issue with this guy is one he
doesn't have any of the practical
experiences and he's speaking to someone
who is in there and he's come in with a
completely closed mind like i already
know the answers it's like at least be
open-minded
you haven't even been through it i'm not
saying the other guy's inherently right
but you you haven't been through it and
you talking like what do you mean you
don't have roles
why don't you ask him straight up like
okay well tell me more about that how
does that actually function i want to
hear your persona it's not that this is
one of them live so it's like uh come on
so i can tell you what it is even though
you're not an expert in the field
no he's an expert in the field no this
is
this is a off-brand kevin samuels yeah
this is somebody who found out somebody
died and said oh there's a market i can
capitalize on that's what happened
that's all that happened yeah i agree so
me watching this dude i feel like most
of this stuff is goofy you guys don't
have to exist
because those don't exist
like i'm not white
what what are you talking about
ain't got nothing to do with white
this is rich and poor baby
that's what it is
i'm not a white christian what
man
what are you talking about i'm not white
what does that have to do with anything
oh because you're trying to you're
trying to live up to like some white
supremacist ideal of okay you went left
right there right there you went left
that's that's
although
i see where you're coming from
but no
that's not really what it is and where
it comes from but
uh but i see
where you're saying why you say that but
no
no no both of these sides are so [ __ ]
insufferable no bro no you were doing
five at the beginning you were saying
some [ __ ] goofy ass [ __ ] what's the
white supremacy
yes the reason why for [ __ ]
millennials okay women have been staying
at home with the kids and taking care of
everything is because of white supremacy
even before the white man ever landed in
africa it's because of white supremacy
jesus in every
not every but most in every
no you're right not in every but in most
places in on earth
before that it was like that so you
bringing that [ __ ] up
corny
but
no yeah
teamwork makes the dream work frank we a
team ain't no roles
what do you mean there ain't no roles
i it's not that hard to understand you
said why do women not want to cook and
clean they're tired they have to go to
work okay i answered that question okay
you said what are your roles
if they're if they're if there's
something that needs to be built in the
house who builds it you or your wife it
depends on what it is
what do you mean depends on what it is
like if it's a toy for the kids you know
what i'm saying my wife's better at
putting stickers on so she builds it but
if we're talking about that's not
building nothing man
i mean i'm sorry you feel that the man
was trolling him at the end
no i don't think he would with the
stickers and then he was i don't think
he was struggling because he wants he
knows each side knows where each side is
going yes each side
no but they're not trolling is an intent
of this is being disingenuous this is
natural this is not me being like
i'm going to laugh
you know what i mean
because
it changes the mindset where you're from
when you're trolling you come from a
yeah i'm not serious this comes from uh
no i'm not gonna budge one is trolling
the other one is being disingenuous it
changes the whole
the intention of what you're doing
probably the end meaning which is doing
and what you're saying is probably the
same but your intentions in the back and
they're not the same yeah so this guy is
not trolling he's being oh i don't wanna
no in my house in my household uh i
built i built [ __ ]
my point watching this is just people
are so rigid with how they view the
world not recognizing the world isn't
what it used to be 60 years ago it's not
because of feminism or this and that the
economy is where it's at both people got
to work both people got to have a job
all right
to me just i listen to this talk and
everything's so rigid so it's
uninteresting to me on both sides yeah
that's the thing is both sides and dude
was saying some pretty
some good stuff at the beginning but
then after that he went left oh my god
he swerved yeah
there's not much to say to this thing i
mean
it's really logical
go outside
this
this world is really not made right now
to be alone
it sucks
it's the way it's really hard to live
alone and and and and make it and
getting by
i don't know if you do this [ __ ] from
your mama basement or you capping
brother but
or where you live or you got some kind
of privilege but go outside go outside
go do some groceries go outside and go
live go pay electricity bills and like
go just go have a little bit of
experience go live a little
go live a little and then after that
talk to me about ah girls don't want to
do that
go go go there was a reason why women
was not working
i'll also say
if you are one of these high value men
who have so many options this isn't even
a bother for you
it should be easy for you to find a
woman who cooks and cleans or pays a
month to do it bruh even when i was poor
i was able to find a bunch of these
women it shouldn't be that hard you've
got so many options you can exercise
right yeah so why are you sitting here
crying about why don't we cook it clean
because you got a game
you got options
why are you crying
the only reason you are is because
you're not one of the makers because the
guys i know who are making all this
money and have options they're not
complaining they have so many [ __ ]
options the minute you're at that
position
the minute you're at that position just
stop you get that was that was yeah that
was important even when i was like poor
like there's so many women i met who are
down to cook and clean up wanting to
live that kind of lifestyle so this is
just nonsense you can get it right
that's it which is fine it's fine maybe
you you need to date some more maybe
maybe you need to start trying to
exercise a couple of those options
because i don't think you have and i'm
also gonna lie a lot of single women
have some nasty ass places yeah some
dirty [ __ ] but thankfully i've
had the luxury dating enough to meet
women who do keep their place
exceptionally clean and who do cook very
well so i just don't buy this narrative
we know that some of y'all have nasty
ass places because you take selfies um
[Music]
[Laughter]
you have to understand that not
everything is free in life
right
there's nothing really free in life
nothing so if you want if you want her
to cook and clean you gotta you gotta do
something
she doesn't just
freely cook and clean what do you bring
what is gonna make her cooking clean
make her cook and get you know what you
know what there was a meme that was
talking about oh woman go make me a
sandwich
go ahead i never asked my woman to make
me a sandwich
i don't have
to i'm not bragging
i'm not boasting
i don't have to
why
because if she feels like making me a
sandwich she won't make me a sandwich
and guess what
when i feel like making a sandwich to
her i'ma make her a sandwich if i feel
like brewing her coffee i'm gonna do it
if she does it if she's in the kitchen
she asks me to
i don't need that
but you want a dictate mother i don't
even have to ask
but but but but but you you y'all
complaining
y'all y'all the ones with the games
y'all the one to know how
make her do it
i don't have to spit game i don't have
to do none of that [ __ ]
why
because my dad didn't have to and that's
probably what i've seen
and i just seen my dad to this day
bring [ __ ] to the table if it needs to
bring my mama coffee he moves my mama
coffee and vice versa
i don't know
where y'all been
and how y'all been raised and by who and
what examples y'all got that's what i
had an example yes it's my privilege
that's what i had as an example so
that's why it's truly weird for me to
see that happening but hey to each tale
let us know what you guys think in the
comments